-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
You look sharp.
Thanks for being here, buddy.
-Thanks for having me, Jimmy.
Hello, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, I was noticing a lot
of the projects
you're involved in
involve space.
A lot of things like
"Prometheus" -- space --
"Doctor Strange" -- space.
-Space.
-Yeah. You did "The Martian."
-"The Martian," yes.
-Space.
-Yes. Yeah.
-Are you typecast?
-Yeah, yeah, I guess I'm like
the Colin Firth of sci-fi.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right, yes.
"Pride and Prejudice."
That's funny.
-I flown a fare few spaceships.
So I think I've been barred now
because my insurance premium's
gone up.
-Yeah, exactly.
I have an older picture of you.
Here is 1994.
This is you in a stage
production of "Star Trek."
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-Not bad.
-There I am,
my little live self.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What do you remember about this?
-Yeah, we had a great time
on that.
I was playing Sulu,
and I think one of the things
what you're going to do when
you're flying spaceships,
you just sort of look off into
the middle distance
confused of where you're going.
[ Laughter ]
And there was one time they
forgot the sound effects,
so I had to kind of improvise
and, you know --
[ Whistles ]
"Bridge to Captain Kirk.
There appears to be some
Klingons on Uranus,"
or something like that.
[ Laughter ]
-You did the whistle yourself?
-The whistle, yes.
-It's an interesting story about
how you got the role of Wong
in the first "Doctor Strange"
movie.
You kind of manifested it.
-Well, yeah. Well, as you were
saying, I was doing the film
"The Martian," with my good
friend Chiwetel Ejiofor.
And you know, you're having
lunch,
and "What are you up to next?"
He's doing "Doctor Strange."
You go on the Internet.
There's this character called
Wong.
-Hello.
-Hi. Hi!
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
-Hi! Yes.
-Yeah, my jaw drops.
I didn't have an agent
at the time --
well, for the better part of
eight years.
So I went to him the next day.
"We're going to do a petition
called Wong for Wong."
[ Laughter ]
"You sign it.
Cumberbatch signs it.
That's it."
He's not having any of this.
-Of course, yeah, yeah.
Wong for Wong, no.
-Yeah, so then that's
out of the window.
Cut to a few months later,
I'm filming in Budapest.
I get this mysterious e-mail
with, "Hi, we would like you
to audition for
the part of Lee."
So I was like, "Alright, yes."
[ Light laughter ]
Went on tape, did some tweaks
in Slovakia.
By the time I got to Malaysia,
I got the call from
the amazing Sarah Finn.
"Congratulations, you're going
to have a wonderful time."
I text my friend Chiwetel.
"I'm going to have to
borrow your lawyer."
And he replied back,
"Wong for Wong?"
[ Laughter ]
And I replied, "Wong is Wong."
-Yeah, that's right.
Wong is Wong.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You made it happen.
You made it work.
-And I'm here.
-And you're here
and you're great.
-Thank you.
-When you were growing up,
you said you were
a big Spider-Man fan.
-Yeah, massive.
-You got to be in
"Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
one of the biggest movies ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But a lot of people
don't know this.
You actually played Spider-Man
once before yourself.
You were Spider-Man.
-Yeah, Spider-Wong.
[ Laughter ]
-Where can we see you
as Spider-Wong?
-Well, a long, long, long,
long time ago, Sia,
the amazing singer that is Sia
had called me up for her video
"Breathe Me,"
you know, and said like, "Come
on, I want you to be in this."
You know, I was trying to say,
"Look, I'm trying to be
a serious actor.
I don't know if I should be
in music videos.
What do you want me to do?"
"You can either wear a rabbit
costume or a Spider-Man outfit."
I went, "I'll be over
in 15 minutes."
[ Laughter ]
So I got to my chance
to play Spider-Man.
-This is kind of awesome
right here. Here's you.
There's you as Spider-Man.
[ Laughter ]
This one -- I probably should've
showed this one.
-Oh, yeah, there I am
in full costume.
So there we go.
-Yeah, that's you right there.
Yes, you actually have played
Spider-Man before.
-Yes, I have.
-But now fans are freaking out
because they love you.
They want the MCU to be the WCU.
They want
the Wong Cinematic Universe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Make sure you got
the U just right.
But fans do want you to have
your own Disney+ series.
What do you think of that?
Do you have ideas
for story lines?
-For all of those feelings in
the 312 Wong-tourage fans.
-Wong-tourage?
-Yeah, that's what
I affectionately call them now.
-The Wong-tourage. I love that.
That's going to catch on.
-We have to give them
what they want, clearly.
-There's 312 people
demanding this.
-Don't you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't hear you!
[ Cheers and applause
intensify ]
-Wow!
-Oh, wow.
-People are demanding it.
-Showing you some of
my pantomime skills there.
-Yeah, you're actually very
talented, yeah.
But I think that would be great.
I mean, would you be up
for that?
-I'd love it. I'd love it.
-You would?
Yeah, they do good work
over at Disney+.
There's got to be backstories
and stuff that we don't know.
-Yeah, you know, what happens to
Wong during the infinity war.
You know, there's a five-year
period we can start with.
-What do you think happened?
-Well, he took a deep breath
'cause it was really full-on
out there, wasn't it?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He could've done anything.
-Yeah, yeah.
You know, training his students
at Kamar-Taj maybe.
-Oh, yeah.
I'd love to know that --
what happens at Kamar-Taj,
what happens at --
Yeah, a day in the life.
-Yeah.
-I would love to see.
Yeah, maybe there can be
a scientist.
-You should be in it.
[ Laughter ]
-That's your idea.
I mean, if the people want it.
-I think Jimmy should be in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, Jimmy,
give me some action.
Give me some portals.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
-Yeah, right? You feel that?
-Health and Safety
will patch that up.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's talk "Doctor Strange."
This is a giant,
giant, giant movie.
Congrats.
-Thank you.
-And I would recommend seeing it
in IMAX too
if you can do it because it is
a big, big universe.
Multiverse, really.
And it really is. It pays off.
There's probably -- yeah,
100 different places you go to.
-Yeah.
-It's just a giant world.
I don't know.
It's so amazing to me.
I go, "What's real and how do
you act in this?"
-Well, Charles Wood is amazing
at building the set design.
And obviously we have
the green screen
that takes us to
far-reaching places.
But, you know, massive credit to
the VFX team.
-They do a great job.
What can we say?
What happens in this movie?
-A lot happens.
I mean, from those that have
seen "Wandavision"
and "No Way Home," obviously
the spell that I told him
not to cast has been cast.
The cracks in the parallel
realities are open.
All sorts of characters
are coming out,
and all roads lead to our movie.
-Yeah, congratulations.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Benedict Wong in
"Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness."
Take a look at this.
-Spider-Man -- he has the powers
of a spider.
-Hence the name.
-Gross.
Does he look like a spider?
-No, no, more like a man.
-Climbs walls. Shoots webs.
-Yeah, bingo.
-Out of his butt?
-No.
-Ew.
-Maybe, I don't know.
Honestly, I hope not.
-Super weird.
-You're going to get
a stomach ache.
-I'm from another universe.
How do you know my stomach works
the same as yours?
-I don't.
I don't even know if you're
from another universe,
which is why I'm still
sitting here
waiting for you to enlighten us.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Which means...?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Benedict Wong, everybody.
"Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness"
is in theaters and IMAX
tomorrow.